was it overwhelming working with uh
Christopher Nolan on Memento was that
was that oh no not at all that was like
he was so such a gentleman and he was so
um that was such an incredible I really
as an actor that was my favorite job
I've ever done oh yeah
um
because you know that feeling that you
have which I have felt in acting class
but is very hard to get between action
and cut
where you forget
that you're acting yeah it's really
tough you know and it's like you get I
mean I've maybe had it I would say in on
screen like
two or three times
you know it's that it's that fleeting
right it it's that fleeting
um you know where you forget
you just didn't and um he created that
energy and
um I
really love that like like Trinity for
instance
like I love her
it was challenging to play here because
she's so still
and every movement it's like you know
what I mean it's so upright it's so
you know centered there's this quality
of
of Stillness with her that isn't really
my like I have to like I had to put a
lid on like every little thing and at
the same time access the life right and
right that's
you know at times I would feel
completely
um like just the mark on the floor just
the T that we stand on like I would feel
like that was jail you know what I mean
like I just like it was like can I not
have a tea like I mean I literally it
was like that like can we take the
middle T out like I'm already confined
enough I I need
the mental bandwidth to like Channel
something right and of course the
directors are so brilliant and the shots
are so brilliant you know but with with
with Memento like and as I'm moving my
body I can just feel like how free I
felt there was a freedom in the acting
um that I really enjoy I like that like
I love like 70s 80s movies right I like
that naturalism and that a shot that
holds the actors and lets them breathe
and act and it's not so many cuts
right I love that I love the breath of
the moments I love not knowing what's
happening so I really got to have that
experience with Christopher Nolan and he
was not intimidating I I I that's like a
word I would never imagine to use
for him I love that I mean that shows
you that shows you the confidence in a
director when they're like they don't it
doesn't have to be this it just I want
you to feel what you're feeling I want
we really stepped back he created the
environment and then guy and I just were
like dancing like it was really it was
really fascinating
you know you did all that work on that
really great script and and
um and then really allowed us the space
to um have the freedom I love God that's
how I felt anyway yeah I love Guy Pierce
yeah me too I think he's the best part
of uh LA Confidential I think he's like
the best in everything he does I I just
am engaged and uh I'm straight but I
think he's hot
he's a good guy
he's an amazing actor he's a very good I
remember at the time and not that it
matters right like Awards who cares but
like I was really surprised that he he
didn't yeah receive that for those kinds
of accolades because he was so good